Jennifer Lopez and lin-manuel Miranda  take it to the streets  the powerhouse duo collaborated on love  make the world go round a song they  recorded as a tribute to the victims of  the pulse nightclub shooting in Orlando  but from the looks of these pics on the  set of the music video the two are  finding some light in the dark JLo in a  colorful halter top waving to fans land  all smiles in a casual blue shirt the  video was shot on the rooftop of the  Richard Rogers theatre the home of  Miranda's Broadway hit Hamilton and eye  witness tells et as the shoot went on  more and more fans arrived and it began  to get really crazy the theater is by  Times Square so of course everyone just  started gathering and it got insane the  eye witness ads you could tell  considering everything going on right  now that they were emotional because of  the songs deep meaning but they kept the  vibe upbeat and positive